farmer accountable and I must say big
farm has also been working with us to
try and get prices down and if we had
support with the Democrats I must say we
could get it down even more we've
reduced prices now by a quite a bit and
this year is the first year Alex Acosta
right in 54 years 53 years that drug
prices have come down and I want to
congratulate you and all the people that
have worked so hard with you that's
really an incredible first year and we
could get him down a lot more if we had
a little support in Congress and I think
we'll get that support I think that has
to be that has to be a joint if that's
not if that's not going to be bilateral
we're gonna get that done and I think
we're gonna get it done quickly we're
gonna get a lot of support I've spoken
to Democrats and they are in support of
it we have to see if we can actually get
them to raise their hand if they do that
we're gonna see some tremendous cuts in
drug prices so thank you very much Alex
we've asked Congress to support a new
research initiative to find a
breakthrough cure for childhood cancers
and we've begun a public health campaign
to eradicate AIDS in America once and
for all and that's really taking place
like nobody would believe we're looking
at a 10-year plan and at the end of ten
years were going to be in very good
shape who would have thought that was
possible even just a short time ago and
we're making dramatic strides in
combating the opioid epidemic we have it
down by a period of almost a number of
almost seventeen percent this year and
when I heard it I thought they made a
mistake I said you are not real that's
not a real number
and it is very much a real number so
Kellyanne and all of the people that
have worked in worked on that that's a
tremendous achievement and we've worked
with the medical profession and with
doctors and with everybody and to think
that it's 17 percent in one year that's
a that's a tremendous achievement thank
you very much
and we're now working with Congress to
pass legislation that ends surprised
medical building and we're going to have
another big announcement in two weeks
unrelated but something that's going to
have a profound effect on the things
that we're talking about and have been
talking about over the last two and a
half years it's gonna be something
really incredible that'll take place
over the next two weeks that'll be a
very big announcement nobody knows what
it is it's gonna be a big surprise but
it's gonna be a very pleasant one no
American should be blindsided by bills
for medical services they never agreed
to in advance we're promoting price
transparency to force competition and
drive down cost and that's what's
happening and that's one of the reasons
we're getting the drug prices stopping
from those tremendous increases that
have taken effect for so many years for
so many decades they've been going only
in one direction up and now we have them
breaking even and going down we're
defending Medicare and Social Security
for our great seniors were eliminated
and we have eliminated Obama cares
deeply unpopular individual mandate
penalty and you know how bad that was
think of it you paid a tremendous amount
of money for the privilege of paying so
that you don't have to pay for bad
insurance okay how bad does that get
that's got to be a first nobody's ever
heard of that one but we eliminated it
it's gone so you're saving a lot of
money and it's a terrific thing and we
will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions always we're
always going to protect the patient's
pre-existing conditions and today I'm
pleased to announce another
groundbreaking action we are
dramatically increasing the ability of
Americans to access more affordable
health insurance through options and
through their employers we're doing so
by expanding health reimbursement
arrangements or HRAs as they are
commonly known HRAs will allow American
workers to shop for the plan that's
right for them and their family and have
their employer cover the cost and it's a
reasonable cost and people are going to
be getting tremendous benefits this will
be possible because HR a's will now
receive the same tax treatment that
other employer provided health plans
have always enjoyed there was a lot of
restrictions and it was impossible until
now this is something that it's time has
come
it's popular it's really really been a
success and I think this is going to be
for many people this will be the way of
the future the previous administration
imposed crushing fines and other
penalties on HRAs to prevent employees
from selecting the plan of their choice
it was impossible with today's action we
are eliminating all of those
restrictions and thanks to the changes
we're making an estimated 11 million
Americans will now choose their own
plans with the help of the HRAs this
will increase the size that
is a very big deal this will increase
the size of individual market by at
least 50%
improving choice promoting competition
and lowering costs for the American
people HRAs provide another important
option to help even more employers offer
great health insurance and the benefits
to the American workers will be
incredible they will be especially
useful for small employers an estimated
90 percent of the businesses that will
take advantage of HRAs have fewer than
20 employees this announcement is a
monumental victory for small businesses
for their workers and previously
uninsured Americans who will now have
access to high-quality health plans of
their choice with us today is one of our
nation's wonderful small business owners
Tony
Conkel from Maryland and I will say Tom
you come up where is Tom are you up here
someplace Tom I have not met Tom well
your handsome guy come on up here
tom Kunkel would you say a few words and
let him know what's just happened to you
please
first of all I'd like to say happy
birthday to the president thank you a
lot of people from my office are also
I'm three years ago I actually spoke to
the US Senate small business and
entrepreneurship committee about
reinstating the health reimbursement
benefit program that had existed
previously this was after the Obama
administration had made it illegal for
our business to help employees but there
are health insurance cost at the time we
have been helping our employees some who
have had very serious three years many
about reinstating health ravers and the
president and the administration for
supporting this new measure and all of
his pro small business policies we very
much appreciated the small business
community so this new role would really
allow small businesses to offer a better
conditions including cancer and after
the bottle rolling and options for them
and also for employers so again I thank
you very much mr. president
also we're joined right now Andrea burns
a small business owner from Pennsylvania
please come up Andrea please
[Applause]
hello my name is Andrea burns and I'm a
director at Richard s burns & Company a
family owned and operated construction
waste material recovery and processing
facility in Philadelphia we employ
approximately 100 people and right now
my brother and I Alan choose the
healthcare plan for all of those
employees they don't have the
opportunity to choose the provider the
coverage or the premium this plan HR
aise would allow us to give them the
opportunity to choose the plan that's
best for them use it well Andrea thank
you well thank you very much it's gonna
be a great there'll be a great
difference I've repeatedly called on
Congress to work with us to bring down
the cost of health care and prescription
drugs
so all happening it said more than 120
Democrats in Congress have signed up for
the bernie sanders massive government
takeover of health care that's gonna
hurt a lot of people it's gonna hurt our
country socialist health care would
crush American workers with higher taxes
long wait times and far worse care their
plan would eliminate Medicare as we know
it and terminate the private health
insurance of 180 million Americans and
even more than that now on my watch we
will never let that happen we will never
be a socialist country
we have to reject the socialist model
that rations care restricts access
Slash's quality enforces patience unto
endless wait lists instead we believe in
freedom we believe in choice we believe
in the highest standard of care in the
world
anywhere in the world and we believe
that American families must always have
the right and the power to choose the
very best treatments plans doctors for
themselves and for their loved ones they
need that freedom they have to have that
freedom and that's exactly what today's
action is all about we're putting the
people back in charge with more choice
for better care at a far lower cost and
other people will not be paying for
their health care we won't be raising
taxes we won't be taxing you into
oblivion we won't be raising the tax
rates to 90 percent I've heard 90% the
only problem with that one it doesn't
come even close to taking care of the
situation so that means you have to go a
lot higher than 90 percent I don't think
that's gonna work too well in this
country we've lowered taxes we want to
keep them down that's very important
and we will not rest until Americans
have the health care system they need
and deserve the system that finally puts
American patients first I want to thank
everybody for being here it's a very
important day a very special day god
bless you and God bless america thank
you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sauer is gonna be the fresh secretary
right
okay so congratulations I'm the first
working mother to ever hold this job to
be empowered to be the spokesperson for
the United States I think that as a kid
and certainly as a parent there is
nothing that could be more terrifying
for a kid to go to school and not feel
safe so I'm sorry that you feel that way
I think that's a ridiculous and
outrageous claim and doesn't dignify our
response from this podium I'm not
finished
there's a very big difference between
making honest mistakes and purposefully
misleading the American people